Alright folks, welcome back.
This lesson I'm going to talk about the idea of multiple setups inside of the trading sessions.
So there's a morning session and there's a PM session when you're working with the New
York index futures.
If you look at the market in terms of a split day, the New York lunch hour between noon
and 1 o'clock PM New York local time, 830 in the morning to noon, that's essentially
the morning session.
There can be multiple setups inside of that.
Now some of the things I've noticed in the comment sections of the videos, some viewers
and students are asking, what do I mean by multiple setups, like what does it look like?
And I kind of want to touch a little bit on that tonight.
Also I want to give you a little bit more perspective on how you can look for additional
ways of trading what it is I'm sharing here.
If we're looking at the S&P futures mini contract for June 2022, you can see we recently traded
up above the relative equal highs.
So buy stops and buy site liquidity were resting right above here.
So as the market drove above that, we always have the likelihood of seeing it continue
going higher.
But whenever it goes above relative equal highs and then we get a swing high like this,
that being high here, lower than the higher candle here, and the next candle after this
candle it has a lower high as well.
So it's a swing high, not to be confused with a fractal that's used like an MT4.
That is not what I'm talking about.
That takes more candles to make it, and by then five candles later, it's just, you've
already missed the move.
So swing high here, since this candle closes the next day, I'm looking for something to
create an opportunity to go short.
So we could be anticipating an open here, rally, power three, which is what I already
taught on the YouTube channel, the accumulation, manipulation, distribution, and then incorporating
the next level of analysis, which is understanding whether we're going to be in a premium or
discount market.
Now, obviously, we're in a premium market, we're above old highs here, we really stretched
out on the upside.
On this high, if we start to go lower, this down close candle is your bullish order block.
The idea of it trading into that down close candle once it goes above these highs, that's
favorable, that's something that could potentially happen.
Now, obviously, I have the benefit of hindsight here, but I promise you, if you study what
I'm teaching you, you'll see this repeating.
So the market does, in fact, trade down into this down close candle, that is your bullish
order block.
But I want to go inside this particular day here, which is obviously Friday.
And we're looking at the internals behind what it is I'm trying to teach you and how
you can find multiple setups inside of each respective session, the morning session and
the PM session.
All right, so here is the hourly chart on the S&P futures mini contract for June 2022.
And I kind of want to bring your mindset back into what we're looking for.
And that is the Power 3, we're looking for an expansion move direction higher or lower.
In this case, we're looking for it to go lower, because we have the daily bullish order block
level, that line here, level 4504.
And look at the lay of the land, okay?
What is it that we see also in the price action?
Well, if we go over to the left, you can see we have relative equal lows.
We have this low, and we have this low here.
So they're relatively equal.
Not exactly, that's why I named them relatively equal lows.
The idea of liquidity resting below here by itself without the order block is likely,
but it's further likely if we have a discounted rate, which is that bullish order block on
the daily chart.
So we have multiple factors here leading to the likelihood of this area being probed for
the purpose of pairing liquidity, the sell stops basically being rated.
Initially in the morning, we were seeing the market trade higher, higher, higher, higher.
And then we broke lower, attacking the sell side liquidity here, and then aggressively
running into the daily bullish order block.
I want you to take a look at this framework from this high down to this low, and this
being a fulcrum point, that being if this high trades to this low and we break this
low, how far can we go down?
I'm going to touch on that in the next slide.
But for right now, I want you to think about how the opening price, what's the opening
price?
Well, there's two.
If you're trading index futures, the opening price is midnight at New York time, and that's
this candle here.
That's the opening price here.
And then there's another opening price at 830 in the morning.
What's the opening price in the candle that begins 830?
It doesn't matter what candle you use.
I see a lot of questions popping up about that.
What's the opening price and what candle do you use?
Soon as you have 830 beginning a new candle, it could be a one-minute candle, it could
be a three-minute candle, an hourly candle, 15-minute candle, whatever that opening price
is, that's what you want to note at 830.
So if you're bearish, ideally, you want to see the market trade above that opening price.
This is going to be manipulation.
The manipulation is the running above a key level when we are bearish.
We're expecting this to go lower.
All of this is basically market protraction, where it's a Judas swing.
The market's going in the opposing direction that it's likely to go to later in the day.
So later in the day, we expect this to go lower.
Where's it going to go?
Below this low.
If it accelerates below this low, where could it go?
Below here.
Okay, then we have the bullish order block on the daily chart.
So we have a lot of things coming together that draw on a great deal of probabilities.
Now probabilities are not absolute guarantees.
That's not the case in trading.
If that was the case, I would never take a losing trade.
You would never take a losing trade.
You stop losses and it would be great.
Unfortunately, we have to contend with risk.
That being the case, we have to at least build the idea around the likelihood of a scenario
unfolding, but being prepared if it doesn't.
So if this market's opening here at midnight and it starts to rally, we can anticipate
this selling off.
But if it can sell off from here and trade below this low, how much further can it go
below these relative equal lows?
Obviously, we have the daily bullish order block level here.
Right here.
Let me take you back up real quick.
That's this level here.
The opening price on this down close candle, that's the order block.
Extending that line out in time, you end up with this on the hourly chart.
So we drop down into that level and look at the reaction there.
It's nice, isn't it?
So going below this low, that's the initial target.
Then reaching below the relative equal lows over here, because that's where sell-solid
liquidity is residing, then tapping into that bullish order block on the daily chart.
But how much further can we go below that level?
How far beyond the actual order block level can we go?
Well, I'm going to zoom in on a 15-minute time frame.
I've already taught this in other lectures, but I want to revisit it here because this
is what you're looking for when you're doing your analysis.
When everything starts to show a willingness to want to go lower, how do we know it's going
to go lower?
Well, we have the swing low here, decisively broken.
See that?
This low, broken hard.
Then we trade back up into the imbalance here, so the fair value gap, we trade up into it
here.
At this point, we anticipate the candles past this or the new forming candles to trade lower
and trade below this low.
And if it does go below this low, we're looking at this price point here, that low, as a fulcrum
point.
That being measuring this high down to that low, that same measurement of distance, and
we expect that projected lower.
Okay, so this is my swing trading model, and I'm applying it to targeting.
So the way you do it is you take your Fibonacci and you anchor it to the highest body.
It could be an open or a closed, it doesn't make a difference, but you anchor it on that.
Notice I'm not putting it on the high here, and I'm doing the same thing with the lowest
open or closed in this swing low.
This retracement up, I'm measuring the distance in terms of range with the bodies of the candles.
The first time I taught this on YouTube, I had a lot of folks scratching their head and
many trolls saying, he doesn't even know how to use a Fib.
I'm showing you how the algorithm is going to read the price.
The wicks and the tails are all distractions.
That's all going to be largely attributed to what the, especially if you're trading
with Forex, and obviously I am aware that this is not Forex, but I learned this through
the models that I employ with Forex.
Now it's a carryover in terms of analysis because you can apply it here as well.
It wasn't always like this.
When there was open outcry only and there was no electronic trading, this wasn't as
pure as you're going to see and has been shown in the past by me in other videos and examples.
By having a measurement from the highest body in this swing up, in this swing low, the lowest
body, that means the lowest open or closed, I'm anchoring the Fib on that.
The settings on the Fibonacci I've included here, and these are the ones that's highlighted
for this illustration.
Below this low, we're looking for it to run into sell side.
If it goes below this low and aggressively expands lower, this could be your next target,
45, 14 and a half.
If it goes below this one, we can anticipate it trading down to what?
45, 0, 1 and a quarter.
The question you're going to probably have in your mind is, okay, this is all fine and
but how do we know which one to pick ICT?
If you put a thousand lines on your chart ICT, eventually they're going to, somebody's
going to see one of those levels get hit and then you're going to make a video and say,
see how smart I am?
I've seen all of your arguments.
I've seen that kind of stuff tossed around in the forums and such.
If we look at the idea that 45, 0, 4 and a quarter is just below what level?
That daily bullish order block at 45, 0, 4, well at 45, 0, 4 and we're getting a measurement
down here, that means we could see it trade down to that level here.
Now if you look up here at this level right there, that low is exactly the candle's low
right there.
Don't take my word for it.
Go to the trading view, pull up the June contract for 2022, e-mini S&P.
That is your daily low.
You can't predict daily highs and lows ICT.
That's impossible.
Well it is possible if you understand the elements that these algorithms operate under
and my question to you is, can you get any better than that?
Is there any other measurement in terms of precision that gets you any closer to 45,
0, 1 and a quarter?
Not when the low is 45, 0, 1 and a quarter.
Look at the reaction there.
Now the order block level is just right here but it stabs down into what the algorithm
is going to measure.
So there's the order block, it wants to go down to it anyway, there's relative equal
lows, it knows there's liquidity down there and you have the measurement.
So the precision element is only going to be beneficial if you have all the other narrative
incorporated with your analysis, that being the market's likely to go lower because we
ran out those relative equal highs on the daily chart.
We created this swing high.
We broke lower aggressively.
We're likely to trade into that daily bullish order block.
Then we have this retracement here.
It completely closes in all the imbalance that's between this low and this high of that
candle.
It rebalanced all that and then we roll over.
Here's that gap I mentioned.
Trades up into that.
We anticipate what?
The candles after this candle closes.
We want to see acceleration to the downside.
We get it.
Market starts working lower, lower and finally right on a dime.
That candle is that low and that's your swing projection I teach in this YouTube channel.
You will not get that measurement if you use this swing high and that swing low.
That's why everybody that uses Fibonacci struggles.
Oh, Fibonacci is a joke.
It's not a joke if you are doing the measurements correctly.
Now, these are just targets, but they are more meaningful when you apply and layer other
things in analysis like the purpose of running to liquidity below those relative equal lows
into a discount array, which is the bullish daily order block.
When you bring that together, you get these types of results, which is perfection.
There's nothing better than this, folks.
You cannot improve upon perfect.
All right, so taking this a little bit further, now we're into a 15-minute time frame.
The opening price again is this candle here, which is midnight New York time.
The opening price, that candle, you extend that out in time.
If you're bearish and you are looking at your daily chart because the majority of your analysis
should be framed on your daily chart, where is it likely to go?
Where is the expansion likely to take price higher or lower?
That's the main thing you're trying to look for because that's going to carve out your
bias.
So, if you know that the likelihood of price wanting to draw down to this daily bullish
order block and we have that level of 45.01 in a quarter, which is that candle's low,
we don't need to have that yet, but we know that this is going to be a draw on liquidity
because it's also below those relative equal lows that I mentioned when we were looking
at the higher time frame chart.
So, all of this here is a buildup into the premium.
The market then breaks aggressively.
What does it create here?
What happened here?
We have a displacement down.
Did that take out that swing low?
Yes.
Does it trade up into that imbalance right here?
Does it trade above the opening price?
Yes.
How many boxes did we just check off there?
A whole lot.
The markets are now going through the roof that this is bearish.
Then the market breaks lower, trades down to the old swing low, sell side liquidity
resting below there.
Watch what happens.
We trade down through it and then we aggressively rebalance all of this down move.
We come right back up into it, bearish order block, then sells off another weight into
this short-term low, deeper below this low, and into, eventually, into the lunch hour
and past it for the daily bullish order block.
Now when you look at this type of price action, you might not see that as an entry, but it
is taught to you in this mentorship on YouTube.
That is the lesson right here.
Because if you look back here, we have these highs.
We trade above it.
Does it break below?
It does.
Does it give them imbalance?
Yes.
Does it trade up in here on the 930 opening?
Then does it run where we want it to?
Liquidity and discount array in the form of a bullish order block.
Yes.
But what other setups are here?
Because I mentioned in my Real Money Real Results series where I was showing actual
live account results and proving that these things make money, not just in demo.
By the way, I appreciate all the feedback I'm getting in the commentary section of each
video, the comment section.
But I've read a lot of the questions about, you know, what do I mean by having no more
than four trades, two trades in the morning, two trades in the afternoon?
What did I mean by that?
Because I read one guy, he was saying, I can't even find, you know, four examples of this.
I may not be saying this correctly, but he can't find that many examples of it forming
over the course of a week, let alone a few times an intraday.
So we're going to walk through today's price action and show it with clarity.
All right, so here's the opening price again on a five minute chart.
Here's the 15 minute time frame, fair value gap, and the market trades right back up into
it about the opening price.
That's what it would look like on a five minute chart.
Notice it does not look clean like it does on the 15 minute time frame.
Let's go back up one more time.
See the gap here in that run right there at 930.
That coupled with this time frame, you probably wouldn't see that as a sell.
You would want to see this filled in, but you've got to look at the higher time frame.
The higher time frame, 15 minute time frame is providing you the framework.
It's giving you context that, okay, this is all we need.
We don't need it to trade up into that.
It could, but we don't need it to.
So when it trades up there, then it starts to break down.
It rebalances, breaks down again, works into that short term low, sells off again, retracement
sells off again.
In here, this is your entry at the opening.
So in the morning session, you typically have two to three setups because you have volatility
coming in at the opening, opening being 930, New York local time.
That can be very tricky if you're not really sure what you're doing.
You can get caught up in the initial volatility and offside real quick and it can run against
you aggressively and hurt you.
I prefer to see my students look for the initial move to kind of like qualify what you're expected
lower prices.
Right?
So does it give it here?
Yes, it does.
How can you participate in something like that and still have the bias behind you and
have multiple setups that you can take?
Well, let's take a closer look on the lower time frame.
Here's the one minute chart.
Here's that return back up into the fair value gap on the 15 minute time frame and wasn't
so clear with the five minute.
But now look what we have here, small little imbalance there, that fair value gap rate
above a short term high.
We trade up into that there on a one minute chart.
You would see that as a setup for the one minute chart.
Before I go any further, I want you to pause the video.
I know some of you don't like to do this because you just want to get through it.
You're watching the video at two times the speed because I talk slow.
This is a time when you want to stop, slow down because you will cheat yourself out of
learning.
This is the little moments like when I'm teaching my private group.
These are these opportunities.
If you waste them, you do not learn the best way.
There's a good way of learning and there's the best way of learning.
The best way is actually participating, not just casually watching.
Don't Netflix binge watch ICT.
This is where you stop the video, ask your spouse or whatever, give you a couple minutes
to focus undisturbed.
That way you can pull out the things I'm trying to show you in this lesson.
Otherwise, it's just another event where I'm talking about hindsight.
What I'm showing you here is something that repeats every single day.
This is how I can go in every single day and take money out of the marketplace.
I took the live account up another $1,000 today, so we're over $51,000.
These are the types of setups that you can do.
You can find these and you don't have to have the absolute perfect entry at the opening.
You don't need that.
That's the benefit of what I'm sharing here publicly.
I want you all to have the ability to feed yourself and your own family, not to rely
on a job.
If you look for these types of setups with this logic, I am confident that you can do
what I just said.
Those that really want to supercharge it can take it way beyond that, competitions, whatever.
We have the logic here.
That's that old short-term low.
All I did was extend the line out because it doesn't exist in the chart over here because
I don't have enough of the data showing, but that short-term low, that was a fall chrome
point, remember?
That's this low here.
So I'm referencing that so that there's where the sell-side liquidity is, but I want you
to pause the video and go through this price action and find the setups that you would
see as a shorting opportunity if your bias was in line with what I'm suggesting here
as it should have been, being bearish.
Okay, I'm going to continue the conversation.
If you are not ready, you missed your opportunity.
All right, so the first fair value gap here, right there, because we have this short-term
low broken with the run lower.
So there's displacement there, obvious displacement, very energetic, and we have this candle's
high, this candle's low, and the market returns back up into it.
You can go short there and look for what's the first objective?
That fall chrome point, that short-term low, aim for the liquidity so your target would
be there.
So you could do like, say you did two contracts entry here, short here too, you can take one
off here, let it ride, and then see if you can get that lower timeframe objective later
in the day.
Now I don't want to take entries during the lunch hour between noon and one o'clock, but
you can take profits if you're doing like a partial, like if you did one here, I'm sorry,
if you did two short contracts here, you took one off at your first target, and you want
to see if you can get the other objective.
If you have a limit order at the order block level, plus a couple points, it could fail
during the lunch hour.
You don't need to be babysitting it, being in front of it then, because you've already
funded your position and trade by taking one off here off and moving your stock to break
even in this, see what it can yield in terms of the daily range.
Next one is here, another short-term low taken, fair value gap there, we trade back up into
it, that's a short.
You can go short here, and again, same premise, looking for the first run below here, that
will be your target taken there.
If you did multiple contracts, you would get short here, take two, take one off.
This might scare you, not so much probably if you were short from up here, but here could
be a little bit intimidating.
But if you've taken one of the contracts off below here, even if it were to come back up
and take you out and stop you out, the first contract allows you to be profitable.
So it kind of balances things out.
Another one is here.
We have the imbalance here, after we aggressively moved lower and then retraced back up in.
This is why I'm saying that that previous short, if I was short from here, I wouldn't
be worried about this one so much because your stop would be above here.
Now it got close to it, but I've been in many trades over the years where it moved within
a quarter of a point without stopping me out.
And it's a scary feeling, especially if you have a lot of size behind your positions at
the time you're in the trade, but it's still a little intimidating because if you completely
fulfill your model and follow it and all the rules and you don't want to move your stop
and you just allow the stop to be taken, there's been many instances in my own trading where
within a quarter point, it doesn't stop me out.
It's not like Forex.
These markets are a little bit more professional in the sense that they're much more precise
and uniform in the delivery.
You don't get these wild, erratic little spikes in spreading of the price action because everybody's
working with the same price here versus in Forex, you're trading within a pool of liquidity
within your brokers in-house and they have a little bit of luxury there where they can
open that spread on you.
And that's why it's a little bit trickier to operate in that versus something like this
market here.
It doesn't mean I don't love Forex still, I do, but right now Forex is just quiet.
It's not doing things that I would promote in my students' attention.
I'm telling all my students, both in my private group and you all here, that this is the
markets that you should be following.
These markets right here, the index futures.
I'm sure there'll be a time when we transition from index futures back to Forex, but until
I see them loosen up a little bit in the currencies, my attention is here.
So anyway, getting short here, this is a shallow run below the old low.
So we anticipate it to run a little bit deeper and it does.
So you can take profits below this low here as a partial.
And then you've seen now obviously multiple opportunities within the same morning session.
So it's also showing you how, if you miss your entry, how can you get back in line with
the marketplace and still participate in these moves?
Now there are going to be days where we don't have this many retracements back and back
and back and then goes lower.
It'll be just one or two and it just keeps on going.
Or many times it'll be just right at the opening and that's it, you missed it.
It just goes right to where you thought it was going to go for the day.
And you can't get mad about that.
You should be happy that your analysis concepts are speaking to you with that much clarity
and just know that because they repeat, none of you should be upset that you missed a trade.
Like none of you, nobody has the permission.
You have no right to be angry about missing a trade because they are like buses.
That's transit buses that come by like a schedule.
Every certain time of the hour or day, these buses are going to come around.
These trades are just like that.
You can set your clock to them.
They're going to form, they're going to be there.
Your number one goal is to understand where is it likely to go to?
Where is it likely to reach for it?
If you have that understood, it becomes so easy to know what you're looking for.
Notice what I said there?
It becomes easy to know what you are looking for.
I did not say it's so easy for you to make money.
There's a strong contrast there, okay?
But by default, over time, once you have been doing the things that lead to you understanding
what is you're looking for, and that part becomes easier, what do you think the default
result was going to be from that?
It's probably going to be easier for you to make money over time, okay?
So I'm keeping things in balance so that we understand what I'm saying without sure
coding it and making it sound like anybody can walk in here and do this.
It's going to take some effort.
Now, you're probably looking at that pink rectangle asking yourself, what the heck is
that?
Well, that is the PM session by side liquidity pool.
What does that mean?
This high here was the most energetic one in the morning session.
It took us all the way down to what target we were looking for, the daily bullish order
block.
Because it's Friday, because it hit the daily timeframe objective, it's in a discount market.
It's really traded lower.
End of week, there's going to be a retracement back into the weekly range.
What can it aim for?
Well, it can aim for the liquidity resting right here because a lot of people are going
to say, well, this is the place where my stop should be at because I want to hold on to
this thing over the weekend.
Now, I don't know who has the courage to do that anymore with all the things going on
around the world.
I personally don't have the courage to hold over the weekend.
It's just too many things can go wrong.
I'm not sitting in a potential opportunity where it's a thousand point gap against me
when we start trading on Sunday.
No, thank you.
I'll pass on that.
But this area here is where you would anticipate on Fridays where liquidity could be a draw
because it's going to likely pull back up into a premium.
What does that mean?
Here's 830.
Here's the turning point at the 930 rotation.
So this high, or we could use this high here, it doesn't make a difference, but I'm going
to use this one because we're framing the logic behind this day being bearish.
So this high down to our target, if you put a Fibonacci on this low to high and find the
50% level, this is above 50%.
So that means above here, that's a premium.
So the market is going to move from what?
A discount to a premium.
That's what the market does.
That's the algorithm does.
It seeks discount to premium, premium to discount.
Within that logic, the market is reaching for liquidity in the form of buy stops and
sell stops and or imbalances or the creation of an imbalance, fair value gaps, or returning
back to a fair value gap.
That's all these algorithms do and they do it on the basis of time, then price.
Now that's gross oversimplification by me, but by far and large, that's all these things
do.
It's not your buying and selling pressure.
It's not the effects of the DOM.
I got a lot of people asking me because they watched me show things in my live account
and they think I trade with the DOM.
I don't trade with the DOM.
I'm not looking at the DOM, trying to read how many orders are resting above or below
because there's spoofing that goes on and those orders may not be there when the price
goes there.
I don't think that the DOM is something that is useful.
I'm only throwing it in here because I saw a lot of people in the comments asking about
those types of things and I don't use them.
I don't use them in my trading and I don't think there's anything in terms of advantage
in using it.
If you believe you're being profitable because you are, don't let my comment change your
mind and I'm not trying to open up a dialogue for debate because you're never going to convince
me.
You're okay if you're using it but I'm answering students or viewers and that's my opinion.
I'm not trying to begin a debate about it.
We have a PM session buy-side liquidity pool that the market could likely reach up into
and again the logic is we move from this high down to a target.
It's Friday.
There's probably going to be position squaring.
They're going to want to take the market back higher so what are they going to reach for
as an opposing move?
Notice what I'm saying here.
This was the target.
There's going to be short covering.
Who's short covering?
The smart money that's sold short here, here, here, here, here and here.
So if they're covering a short are they bearish still?
No.
So if they're not bearish what are they?
Polish.
So if they're going to be smart money and buy down here or they're going to use this
imbalance in here if it trades down into that you can see a run higher.
If they're going to buy it what are they going to target?
The buy stops up here and they're going to sell right to those buy stops.
They're buying this and selling it to these leading buyers on their buy stops.
Notice these relative equal lows.
They take it into the order block right below those relative equal lows because it sells
what?
It sells the retail crowd that this was support broken.
What are they going to want to do?
When it trades back up into these relative equal lows they're going to do what?
Sell right?
That creates more liquidity for buying.
So this is engineering buy side liquidity on the basis of sell side flow.
Sellers coming in the marketplace.
These sellers they're going to have a counterparty in the form of smart money buying it.
They want to sell short because they see relative equal lows breaking.
The trend's been down.
Everything looks bearish to them because it's been going down all day long so they think
naturally it's going to keep going down when it's only traded down to where the algorithm
says this is what we wanted and now we're going to reprice higher.
We're going to move from a discount to a premium.
The premium intraday is going to be this area here and that's going to be where the market
draws to for the afternoon session buy side liquidity.
All right I was going to do the pause the video type thing here but this is going to
be a long video so I'm just going to go right into it.
All right so we have a mitigation block here and I'll teach that in the YouTube channel
but we have market structure breaking.
We come back down into the mitigation block and we also have the imbalance here they got
there so we can be a buyer here.
Remember the 45.32 the 45.40 level go back up to this chart here right in here so this
high right here to here.
Think about those price ranges.
We trade up into it here so buying here and aiming for that liquidity up here that would
be your target from buying to getting out there selling to those waiting buy stops.
The next one is here market trades down in and I count you to go into your chart.
I left this out for your own personal study but if you look to the left go over here you'll
see an old high okay old highs are a discount array if we trade above an old high that old
high becomes a discount array.
This is where not all the time but this is where old highs being broken become support.
That's why sometimes the books have it right.
That's why sometimes your analysis will be right about specific key highs and lows but
notice they're not always consistent and that's the problem so you want to know what makes
a old high or an old low real support or resistance when you have the logic when I'm framing here
because we know that the likelihood of the market is going to draw up into this area
here because that's where the buy stops are resting above the marketplace when it hit
the order block down here.
So what we're saying is the market is going to bounce from here up into this vicinity
here so if the market comes back down in and touches it could have touched this high here
but there's an old high to the left over here you'll see it it trades down and hits that
and it also fills in an imbalance when you have that old highs broken will act as support.
So there's something for your notes.
Then we have the run up into that area so it's not a bad little run.
Now once we get up into that shaded pink area what have we done we fulfilled buy side liquidity
in this area here but we have a little bit more later on which obviously you can see
it runs too but but here we see it do a run lower so we break below a swing low market
structure shifts.
Is there any imbalances in here?
No but there is one right there see that here's your fair value gap shift in market structure
there retraces back up into the fair value gap you can be a seller there and aim for
this low or the order block or you can wait for a confirmation entry which is we turn
here after it hits that fair value gap breaks lower and then we have another breaking the
structure of the marketplace on the one minute chart creates the imbalance here fair value
gap trades up yes it overshoots it but we also have two fair value gaps remember the
rules I gave you if you have a fair value gap and a small one right above it anticipate
it likely trading up into you but use this as your entry.
Go short here and aim for the order block.
So if you have an understanding of how we're going to work within the intraday volatility
using liquidity using the time of day using the day of week all these things come together
and they make a really beautiful tapestry so you can read price action now I know there's
a large number of you that are going to watch this and it's going to feel and seem like
obviously anybody can go back in time and do these types of things but a lot of my
trades when you see my examples and you see the things I record and show you they're using
logic like this so it's not contrived it's not form fitted it's not cherry picked for
the purpose of just being something to talk about this is what you're looking for and
when you do your back testing I've got a lot of questions in the comment section about
this as well you go through your charts just like I'm doing here and you annotate them
now in all these areas where there's empty space here or over here or over here you're
putting in little notations and you're typing them out and yes it takes time yes it's tedious
yes it takes a great deal of effort and desire but this stuff rewards that it rewards it
it's not like fantasy football where you know who cares if your team wins this pays you
this is something that you can feed your family with okay if you need your expenses to be
reduced and you don't want to get enough job or in your you know you take a pay cut maybe
get a you know job loss or whatever this skill set can fortify any weak links in your financial
chain okay you want to build strength in your ability to make income and build legacy wealth
it's worthwhile for you to spend time learning this and that means going back through old
charts and old moves and literally going in and annotating the moves like this and mapping
them out and seeing the logic that's there now do not be afraid that you're going to
do it wrong all of you are going to be doing it wrong in the beginning this is a skill
set in back testing you're trying to discover okay you're not trying to do things correctly
in back testing back testing is you in a mode of discovery that proves efficacy if you can't see
things repeating then you got to go back into the core content lessons of this YouTube channel and
fair it out what it is I'm teaching conceptually then once you understand better what it is I'm
showing you then you go back into the old data and look for those very things occurring then
highlight the things in your chart that makes the most sense to you over time doing it and
frankly you should be doing this at least a minimum of a year okay make it a practice
of doing all the time even when you start trading with live funds your trade journal
should always have annotations you should always have charts saved and just constantly referring
to what you witnessed in price and record it like you saw it happening and knew it was going to
in advance that's called self-talk okay you're literally tricking your brain into seeing your
annotations as something that you foreseen coming and that way when you go back and you read your
journal and you study it on the weekends or you know whatever you go through a period of drawdown
and you need encouragement you go back to your charts in your journal and you'll see annotations
that you wrote out yourself and it tricks your brain believing that you seen that all along now
what happens by doing that over time is you have created creases in your brain where that knowledge
and that pseudo experience has been retained but your brain remembers it as what a real experience
that you endured but you're recording it with positive reinforcement in your commentary never
put negative comments in your annotations don't say like oh I was stupid I missed this oh I'm so
dumb I fell victim to the shark pattern you don't do all that kind of stuff you don't have to worry
about swim with sharks you don't have to worry about animal patterns you don't worry about any
of those types of things all you're looking for is liquidity imbalances time of day that's it that's
it that's all this game is all about okay the algorithm is not going to try to follow some
retail logic stuff it's based on where's the money where's the money who's the most easy prey
right now and where is the majority of the money and that's where it's gonna run for that's all
it's gonna do and if you strip everything you think you know about the markets away and just
give me a couple months stay with me for a couple months here and I promise you you will put
else down and see it like this because this is the truth this is the perfect understanding of what
makes these markets book that means what makes them go up and down where they turn why they go
where they go why are they moving when they move and why are they arriving when they were arriving
at that price point it's all algorithmic and it has absolutely nothing to do with ratios it has
nothing to do with anything harmonic nothing supply and demand zone nothing to do with Elliott
Wave nothing to do it like off nothing to do it again none of that stuff has anything to do with
it I literally have just explained exactly what these markets do that's it there's nothing else
that happens the buying and selling pressure it's a myth because these markets are going to go
higher regardless of how many contracts come in if they want this thing to go up here it doesn't
require millions of contracts to put it there it doesn't how many contracts does it take for
this candle to move from that opening price to that closing price tell me how many camp how many
contracts does it take for that to happen it only needs two two transactions two transactions one
here and when it gaps up here and reprices to that price point and it offers it to the market that
price and someone comes in with a market order what happens boom it's it the candles have been
created two trades how many contracts it doesn't make a difference you only need a transaction
what yeah folks listen you can sit down and listen to these videos I'm producing and come
in with the preconceived notion that everything I'm saying is nonsense it's not true and it's
not valid because you don't want it to be all I'm asking you to do is put everything you think you
understand put it aside for a moment just for a little while and go in and do the things I'm
telling you to do I guarantee you you will absolutely fall in love with this because this
is consistency this is consistency that you have always hoped for but everything else just falls
short in delivering it and you're getting it for free and I'm loving it while giving it to you
because I know and you're all gonna see it when all these little light bulbs come on and all of
people watching these videos and folks this channel is growing it's growing and this chains
gonna keep on rolling yeah this community is getting bigger and bigger because it's infectious
results matter proof matters and when students go into this and they see the results man it's
sweet isn't it isn't it sweet when you see the truth finally just laid out in front of you there's
no trickery here there's no twisting of your arm give me your credit card payment you don't
you don't have to blow any kisses to me okay I don't need flowers I just want you to make a
real effort and then tell me what your results are what did you get from it I promise you I'm
promising you you will find what you're looking for but you got to put the work into it because
if you don't put the work into it it won't matter because you'll just think it's too much
work and I'm telling you it only feels like a lot of work in the beginning but once you understand
what you're looking for like this setup here that might be your particular setup and this up here
isn't your setup this might be your setup here because it's based on that old hi that's you'll
find if you scroll back on your own chart that might be your setup and not this one down here
that's what I'm referring to when I say when you find your unique model that means a setup that
is so similar every time you take it it repeats the same general idea just in a different chart
on a different day in a different time frame it's it that's all it is that's a that's your unique
model you're learning how to do it with what I'm teaching you but where you're looking for it in
what market in what narrative that you're looking for what makes that setup your particular setup
that's a unique thing for you and that's the weird beautiful element to trading and the way
these markets operate is it allows each and every one of us to have our own unique model we can all
use the things I'm teaching and all find setups within the same trading day and be opposed to
every individual trade setup individually in other words we could all be doing something and
not agree with any of it you took a short there I was long a little while before that or I went
short and you went long somewhere else and you're ending a trade where I'm getting ready to put on
a trade it's amazing but how you internalize the market what setup you're looking for there's lots
of them and if you break this chart down into a 30 second chart or a 15 second chart there's even
more setups everything's fractal so if you want to do high-frequency trading you can do that with
the second chart you may not be able to pull up second charts because you may not have the I guess
the subscription level on trading view and I don't get any subscription kickbacks I'm not trying to
get you to buy anything from trading view I'm just stating that you can make this however you
want and if you just want to stay on a 15 minute chart and trade the daily range okay there's no
reason to do anything less than that but if you want to get busy and pyramid your positions that
means like say you bought one down here or say you bought say about five down here and you bought
three here and you bought two here and then you roll it up into your objective that's a
pyramiding your biggest position put on first then a smaller position on and then a smaller
position on and then they that's how you build up the equity and you get velocity in your equity
court that way versus buying one then buying two then buying four then buying eight that that is
reckless and I've done that and I've roasted accounts doing it so don't do that but hopefully
this is at least got your gears turning about how you can go in and back test a little bit how you
can see multiple trade setups and how we can work with higher time frame PD arrays and the PD array
matrix where it's discounted premium and premium to discount and how we use and incorporate all the
different arrays where I'm sure someone new watching this your head spinning right now you're
like I have a thousand questions right now and I need to know this no you don't need to know what
you're asking for right now you only feel like you need to know right now take the things I'm
showing you at the pace I'm showing you study them and I promise a couple months from now you're
gonna know a whole lot more than you know right now and you'll be able to go in and see things
in price action that you don't even identify right now even in hindsight you just got to give
yourself the time and give yourself the real effort to learn this I've stripped it down I mean
it's streamlined as I possibly could and I promise you will get this and it's all talk to you next time be safe